we're heading up towards valentine's day
figuring out to do for your partner for
valentine's day sometimes it's a bit of
a minefield it can be tough well it's
tough enough when you're together but
what if you are have a long distance
relationship and so that's another
hurdle it's like how do you make the day
really special but you're not together
to hold hands or hold each other bianca
holman is live with advice from
long-distance relationship experts and
again i didn't know there was a field of
long-distance relationships
but there's a thing
right bianca yeah it is
it's a thing sherry there's actually a
professor here at unlv teaching a course
about it that's pretty amazing i wish
they had that type of course when i was
at college but
you know what she gave us some great
advice and some great tips to help our
long distance couples make the most of
it and if you think about it it's very
popular we've got our military couples
that often they're
you know spouses deployed or even
college couples right your high school
sweetheart has gone on to another school
so a lot of people
are in long distance relationships and
also the pandemic it has made people
find new jobs in other cities or social
media you find your love online long
distance relationships allow people to
focus on themselves and career when
their partner is away professor jennie
farah at unlv she teaches a course on it
and she says that you have to have the
dedicated quality time when you see each
other farrell says that when long
distance couples reunite permanently
they're twice as likely to break up and
that's why strategies like positivity
assurances and sharing tasks are
important
we tend to like romanticize each other
and then aren't really prepared for the
reality that will happen when you do say
we see each other all the time you
really want to plan for like this weird
transitional period where you've got to
really get used to each other so we even
see this in like couples who are in like
the military
and deploy
so here are some other suggestions for
those who are miles away from their
partner send a personalized care package
flowers and candies those that's cute
but of course make something unique and
it will be more meaningful plan a trip
together instead of visiting each other
city meet somewhere in the middle and of
course you can always do something
before valentine's day like this week in
bianca holmen live local now